durante un discurso de 30 minutos en la
haya el presidente francés Emmanuel
macron llamó a buscar una mayor
soberanía europea durante el marco de su
visita oficial a Países Bajos una nación
con la cual ha mantenido diferencias
durante las últimas décadas
la pandemia y la guerra nos han empujado
a descubrir que debemos reducir nuestras
dependencias y queremos preservar la
identidad Europea de lo contrario poco a
poco seremos dependientes de todo
Después de sus polémicos comentarios
sobre Taiwán y la autonomía estratégica
europea Emanuel macron insiste esta vez
en la necesidad de la independencia
económica del bloque europeo
podemos poner en marcha una nueva
doctrina económica que nos permita
considerar la creación de empleo la
financiación de nuestro modelo social la
gestión del cambio climático y el hecho
de ser más soberanos y decidir por
nosotros mismos
el presidente de Francia llamó a
reforzar el peso de la Unión Europea
frente a China y Estados con el
desarrollo de políticas industriales
ambiciosas pero también con mayor
proteccionismo en sectores estratégicos
como la energía y la ciberseguridad
la Unión Europea se ha dotado por
primera vez de una herramienta para
bloquear o prohibir participaciones o
adquisiciones extranjeras en empresas
estratégicas
[Música]
es un cambio ideológico completo hasta
hace muy poco considerábamos que
estábamos abiertos Sin condiciones
macron también defiende la idea de un
comercio más justo al dejar de firmar
tratados de libre comercio con países
que no cumplan con el acuerdo de París
con el fin de reducir las emisiones de
CO2